okay so this is just going to be a quick
anecdote on the question of how much
sleep does a physics major get in terms
of having to stay up late for
assignments and study and all kinds of
things because that's a question I get
asked reasonably often so my personal
take is that it's possible to go through
a physics degree without doing
all-nighters because I have met some
people who say they didn't do any I did
a few all-nighters and it's mostly
because of like what my personality was
which was that I would do it at the last
minute and it just worked for me at the
last minute because everything was in my
brain at the same time and the only time
I really did all-nighters was lab
reports and handing in like a thesis so
like Mona's thesis I just stayed here
for like 48 hours typing and like
probably the most tired or stressful
time was during a course we did where we
had to hand in a lab report every week
and so this is at least like maybe 10
pages of what you've done in an
experiment every week and for that
course I probably did an all-nighter or
at least a really late night every week
but otherwise like I would probably go
to bed quite early and get quite a lot
of sleep so you can definitely do it if
you if you manage your time yes that
definitely depends on your personality
and how you structure your work if you
want to you can just do all of your work
in the morning you can plan out how
you're going to study but I don't know
many people at all who ever did that if
you do that you can get all your work
done before 5 p.m. and just treat it
like a nine-to-five job someone like me
who needs sleep to function or they
don't function at all I would quite
often I could study up to 9:10 p.m.
during exam time for serious assignments
or for exams that were really close
together I might stay past midnight to
like 2:00 a.m. but then I could just go
to sleep and wake up at 9:00 and get
seven hours of sleep and it'd be fine so
like exams were a weird time I think
because like
common-sense advices to get lots of
sleep before an exam and make sure
you're well-rested and all this but
something about the nature of when you
have like many consecutive exam days
that's not always so possible when
you're still trying to like I don't know
in crayon information before the exam
which it's not also not an ideal
strategy but haven't quite a lot and I
would probably get like five hours sleep
before an exam was kind of normal for me
because I would stay up till midnight
studying with other people at uni go to
bed for five hours and then study again
from like 5:00 a.m. until the exam at
9:00 or something like that I remember
that schedule because that's what I used
to do but we had a friend or a couple of
friends that would just sleep overnight
or have a nap in the physics building
and then at breakfast at uni and walk to
the exam they'd had only had like 15
minutes sleep all night
that sounds horrendous but it happened
and they it worked and they got a good
grades they could do that
yeah just sleep for 15 minutes then walk
into an exam and get an A+ also crash
afterwards but their mind was like so
full of differential equations at the
time that they could it can work so
where is my sort of studying technique
was to wake up around 9:00 a.m. go into
uni and then just stay there until you
want to go to sleep you end up basically
just living physics for about two weeks
oh yeah exam kind of horrific but you do
at least get to sleep so it's yeah and
and when you finish your last exam it's
always like a release because you've
been in that physics mindset just almost
24/7 yeah yeah yeah so I think there's a
few different takes on this but I think
like what James said you can get through
it if you plan at your time work 9:00 to
5:00 like a normal job but there are
definitely times I've experienced and
most people I know in physics exam time
especially studying late at uni or in
the libraries is what happens yeah all
right thanks James